[Música]
ah
sabías que
nueve de cada diez mujeres se sienten
infelices con la manera en la que se ven
el 97% de mujeres confiesa que tiene al
menos un momento de odio a mi cuerpo
todos los días
el 81% de las niñas de 10 años tienen
más miedo a ser gordas ya tener grasa
que a perder a sus padres
las adolescentes de hoy en día tienen
más miedo a subir de peso que a tener
cáncer
nueve de cada diez mujeres se sienten
inconformes con algún área de su cuerpo
y es un pensamiento que están teniendo
recurrentemente todo el día y aún más
radical dos de cada cinco mujeres darían
de tres a cinco años de su vida por
poder ser más delgadas
impactante no creen
estos son solo algunos datos del
instituto de psicología de la
alimentación de colorado en eeuu
he visto a muchas mujeres luchar con lo
que sienten por su cuerpo empezando por
mí
por muchos años cuando me paraba
enfrente del espejo odiaba lo que veía
toda mi infancia adolescencia vive en un
mundo en el que día a día estaba rodeada
de críticas y burlas de forma que al
crecer escuchando todos estos
comentarios negativos me llevó a
sentirme menos y a convertirme en la
peor juez de mí misma
recuerdo que cuando me paraba en frente
del espejo me decía mire esas piernas
miren esa panza o dios los granos
recuerdo que no me pude voltear a ver el
espejo durante años
hasta me hacía flecos muy grandes y del
lado para que no se me pudiera ver la
cara no quería que nadie me viera ya que
me sentía fea e insegura y poco
agradable
mi relación con el espejo era total y
absolutamente destructiva
desde que nacemos estamos siendo
bombardeados por los medios de
comunicación en las redes sociales
acerca de cómo deberíamos de lucir cuál
es la talla que deberíamos de tener cuál
es el estándar que tenemos que alcanzar
para ser hermosas y exitosas si
efectivamente tenemos muchísima presión
por ejemplo nos sentimos incómodas
cuando vamos a probarnos ropa a la
tienda y no nos queda ni remotamente
parecida a como lo hace el alemán y que
también nos sentimos muy presionadas
cuando acabamos de tener un bebé y
tenemos que recuperar rápidamente la
figura de antes de estar embarazadas
nos sentimos muy inseguras cuando vemos
que las modelos o influencers de
instagram o facebook no tienen ni un
gramo de celulitis y nosotras si también
tenemos la constante necesidad de
mantenernos jóvenes y sin ninguna arruga
así que venga todo el botox el ácido
hialurónico los rellenos las cirugías
plásticas para mantenernos eternamente
bellas bellas podrían mencionarles
muchos ejemplos más que reflejan que no
nos sentimos suficientes con el cuerpo
que tenemos
lo que ha aprendido en mi experiencia
profesional y platicando con muchas
otras mujeres me ha llevado a darme
cuenta que lidiar o rechazar a nuestro
cuerpo se ha convertido en algo que
hemos normalizado y esto impacta cada
aspecto de nuestra vida ya que afecta
negativamente nuestro trabajo nuestros
estudios la relación con nuestra familia
y con nuestra pareja nos repetimos
tantas veces odio a mi cuerpo u odio
esta parte de mi cuerpo que no nos
podemos concentrar en nada más
y esto nos hace sentir miserables y
drena toda nuestra energía créanme se
los digo por experiencia
incluso hay muchas mujeres que pueden
llegar a tener ansiedad o depresión por
no sentirse cómodas con su imagen
corporal
he visto a muchas mujeres posponer o
condicionar su felicidad hasta que su
cuerpo no alcance cierto peso o cierta
talla ponemos en pausa nuestra vida
hasta que no seamos lo suficientemente
fit lo suficientemente flacas hasta que
no desaparezca la celulitis y hasta que
no seamos dignas de ponernos un bikini
en el cual nos podamos sentir cómodas y
perfectas lo cual casi nunca ocurre
nos decimos no voy a ser feliz hasta que
pese esto hasta que me quede este
vestido o este pantalón hasta que se me
quite esta lonja de mi cuerpo todo este
tipo de pensamientos son nocivos y
peligrosos ya que nos impiden disfrutar
del hoy del aquí y del ahora
te has preguntado alguna vez cómo sería
el no tener que preocuparte de tu peso
cómo te sentirías en que canalizaría
toda esta energía que ocupas para pensar
recurrentemente en esto
doy consulta a más de 80 pacientes por
semana de los cuales la gran mayoría son
mujeres a las que les hago esta pregunta
constantemente cuántas horas de tu día
pasas criticándote a ti o alguna parte
de tu cuerpo y lo que comúnmente me
dicen es uy crisis sin contar las que me
duermo de 15 a 18 horas o muchas me
dicen desde que me despierto hasta que
me duermo o muchas me dicen sabes gris
este tipo de pensamientos son muchísimo
más recurrentes cuando me baño cuando me
he visto y cuando estoy con mi pareja
para ahondar mucho más en este tema que
me parece muy relevante
me gustaría compartirles algunas de las
historias de mis pacientes
por ejemplo tengo pacientes como mariah
de 43 años a quien detectamos que se
sentía muy presionada por cumplir
ciertos estándares de belleza
ella se atacaba todo el día con palabras
hirientes se insultaba desde que se
despertaba hasta que se dormía
era como vivir con su peor enemigo
me contó que no quería salir en las
fiestas infantiles de sus hijos porque
iba a ser criticada por ser la más gorda
no había manera que fuera el gimnasio
porque no quería verse con los leggins y
que nadie la viera
mariah vivía eternamente a dieta ella
comía compulsivamente para castigarse
por tener falta de fuerza de voluntad
todo esto lo hacía sentir deprimida e
insuficiente
para apoyarla salir adelante hicimos
varias actividades y una de ellas fue
que por cada cosa negativa que se dijera
se tenía que decir al menos tres
positivas por ejemplo cada vez que se
casara diciendo estoy gordísima nada me
queda tenía que decir tres o tres cosas
positivas me encantan mis ojos me
encanta mi sentido del humor y me
encanta que soy un excelente mamá
por otro lado regina de tan solo 14 años
tenía una muy mala relación con ella
misma
ya que pensaba que tenía la cadera y el
cuerpo demasiado grandes
ella no comía
solamente comía hielos para poderse
llenar
ocasionalmente tenía cuadros de color en
contra de sus papás y de sus
compañeritas de la escuela
para apoyarla salir adelante hicimos
varias actividades y una de ellas fue
que escribiera en el espejo de su cuarto
que pusiera en la pantalla de su laptop
y de su celular la misma frase me amó
justo como soy y le repitiera y la
sintiera cada vez que estuviera en
contacto con la frase a pesar de que su
vocecita interna le dijera no es cierto
no te amas nada te vas amar hasta que
baje 10 kilos aún así ella tenía que
seguir firme con la actividad diciendo
me amo justo como soy me amo justo como
soy me amo justo como soy
con sofía hicimos otras actividades y
haciendo una de ellas me comentó muy
preocupada que al estarse repitiendo y
sintiendo estas frases y afirmaciones
positivas le comenzó a salir sangre por
la nariz cosa que no le dio importancia
pero al paso de los días ella seguía
firme con la actividad y no le dejó de
salir sangre de nariz por lo que se
espantó y fue a ver a varios médicos
especialistas que para su sorpresa le
encontraron en perfectas condiciones por
lo que concluimos que probablemente se
debía a una reacción de su cuerpo al
estar escuchando por primera vez estas
afirmaciones y frases positivas porque
nunca en su vida se las había dicho
todas estas actividades que maría regina
y sofía hicieron tuvieron resultados
impactantes por lo que se las propuse a
otras pacientes muchos de sus
testimonios me dejaron en shock al darme
cuenta que a muchas les costaba
muchísimo trabajo verse en frente del
espejo fijamente no había manera de que
lo pudieran hacer en ropa interior y ni
pensarlo en verse desnudas fijamente en
frente del espejo me decían que estás
loca yo hace años no puedo hacer eso aún
así hoy perseveraron y hoy son mujeres
mucho más felices seguras y tranquilas
con la manera en la que se ven
aparte de hacer todas estas actividades
es importante que tengamos un
recordatorio físico de los cambios que
estamos teniendo por ejemplo maría ahora
tiene un collar que le recuerda de que
ya no debe de criticarse y que tiene que
hablarse como si fuera su mejor amiga
sofía compro una de estas pulseras las
que están de moda las que tienen los
dijes y cada vez que la voltea a ver se
acuerda de que tiene que tener un
diálogo interno de mucho más amor y
compasión hacia ella en mi caso es un
anillo en el dedo índice que me recuerda
el compromiso que tengo conmigo misma
para hablarme y tratarme como si fuera
también mi mejor amiga con mucho más
amor y compasión con mis palabras y
pensamientos
mi intención no es de que piensen ay
pues al fin y al cabo la nutrióloga
querida me dijo que tengo que amarme
justo como soy ahora sí vengan todos los
pacos todos los panuchos todas las
pizzas todos los helados sin control
lo que yo quiero proponer es que
tengamos mayor autocuidado desde una
filosofía de amor y no desde una
filosofía de odio o de querer cambiar mi
cuerpo a como del lugar
tal vez tres escuchar a estos
testimonios te preguntarás cómo es esto
posible antes de darte la respuesta me
gustaría que te imaginarás lo siguiente
qué pasaría
y mejorarás
el diálogo interno que tienes contigo
misma
te sentirías más tranquila estaría más
contenta
estudios de vanguardia demuestran que el
cerebro no distingue la diferencia entre
lo que te dices y piensas de ti misma y
lo que te dicen los demás por lo que
cada vez que te ataca te críticas te
exiges a ti misma el cerebro lo siente
como una especie de ataque y esto hace
que la hormona cortisol que es la
hormona que se eleva cuando tenemos
muchísimo estrés aumente y esto nos hace
más propensas a enfermedades
inflamatorias conocidas como las it is
colitis gastritis entre otras por lo que
requerimos tener una reprogramación y un
cambio de mentalidad
para que se creen nuevas redes
neuronales de amor de compasión y de
autocuidado
i
[Música]
te invito a que emprendas una
transformación un nuevo camino no por
cambiar tu cuerpo sino por transformar
la relación con la persona más
importante de tu vida contigo misma con
esa persona que ves todos los días en
frente del espejo porque estoy segura
que de esta manera podrás mejorar tu
vida radicalmente
niñas jóvenes mamás hijas
construyamos una relación de amor con
nosotras mismas que como todas las
relaciones tendrá sus altas y sus bajas
les mentiría si les dijera que es muy
fácil o de que si es de un día al otro
pero estoy segura que si empezamos el
día de hoy y con el tiempo esta relación
se empezará a hacer cada vez más fuerte
te invito a que te transformes a que
sepas que es posible ser feliz sin la
necesidad de lucir de cierta manera que
no necesitas otro cuerpo para poder
alcanzar tus metas y tus sueños y para
tener una vida plena porque ya eres
perfecta tal cual y como eres has
escuchado tantas veces que no eres
suficiente que tienes que escuchar
muchas veces más que si lo eres porque
lo eres porque recuerda que la persona
más importante de tu vida es la que
tienes enfrente del espejo gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]